hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the feeder World Cup 2019 it's a game
one of the match tamer the job of versus
being leerin and well let's just dive
straight into it we don't have any
photos yet since it's only game 1 but we
will have at least some tomorrow so
let's let's just enjoy it with the white
pieces a job of opens with E for now
with E 5 wedding night two of three
nights the c6 and the bishop to be
Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on the
board with a six more fees defense push
up to a four and now Knight to f6 with
castles all standard stuff Bishop to e7
rook to e1 and now b5 with Bishop to b3
castles by ding and now c3 offering
being the the opportunity to go for the
Marshall attack and indeed in this
position being played d5 and we have the
Marshall attack on the board now if some
of you are maybe new to the channel and
if you're interested a bit more in the
Marshall attack do check out the link in
the description below it will be the
first link you see it's the first game
well D the most famous for his game ever
played where the Marshall attack is
being deployed in the game of course
Capablanca versus Frank James Marshall
do check it out it's it's just very nice
so we go into the it captures on d5
the D stand the line Knight captures
Knight captures on e5 Knight captures on
e5 and now rook captures on e5 we have
this position that is always reached
when you go for the Marshall attack
where black has a variety of choices
you've got to go for the older
continuation Knight to Knight to f6 you
can go for c6 which is the most popular
today but should be 7 even like the b6
has been played but here in this game
with c6 biding and here
d3 d4 also playable a Java prefers d3
with Bishop to d6 now getting this very
nice diagonal for his dark square Bishop
rook back to e 1 and now Bishop to f5
Queen to h4 right away just goes into g3
Queen h3 and now look the e4 where the
rook is nicely covering the
fourth-ranked
rook the h4 also becomes a possibility
at some point so the trip to fi of the
preferred idea
and here we have Quinta f3 now going
after the bishop on f5 and now Queen to
h4 biding offering a bishop for a very
nice checkmate on h2 not really not
really a checkmate but a white would be
able to get away for example a Queen
captures on f5 you would get Queen
captures and h2 checking f1 and now okay
you do get a chance to escape but it's
not black will always be better just
gonna put your rook here on the file
captures rook captures and now you have
to block with Bishop to e3 and it's just
a very painful process for white so
instead of going for this first just g3
the bishop is still under attack with
Queen to h3 and now Knight the d2
kurakin had this position against
England in the 2019 sinful cup and their
game ended in a draw kirkin went for
Bishop to e3 here but here we have nice
to d2 and now comes Luke 88 and this is
all very standard for for when you play
a play the marshals gambit the white
will have problems developing the dark
square bishop and the rook but if you if
you play everything well you should you
should you know I'd be out of any
serious trouble Knights the e4 now
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop and the now Bishop to g4 pushing
the Queen back we have Queen to g2
offering a trade of Queens and here of
course the Queen is captured we have
Queen capped nuts
of course not the g3 pawn Queen captures
Queen King captures and now f5 and it's
very interesting here how do you save
the night if the knight moves of course
rook captures rook wins the game so how
do you how do you play this you could
give up the exchange with Knight
captures and b6 of course but that's you
don't really gain anything for it so how
do you save the night a save your piece
here
I feel free to pause the video and try
to find your way out of this situation
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
hidden idea and for those who just won't
enjoy the show
h3 now the point is after the bishop
moves you will either push g4 or the
even better better player for for
example now
eh five was played and now G 4 is
possible where you will either after the
bishop moves pick up the f5 pond which
is attacking your knight or if pawn
captures then your knight is no longer
under attack but there's the there's an
even better after the show to h5 Bishop
f4 is even better and this is why being
played Bishop captures on f4 we have G
captures on f4 and now EKF captures on
e4 and now the point is rajab just plays
D captures on e4 attacks the knight and
the knight is pinned so he will win his
piece back but now you could choose how
to give back your piece so here's
another very nice position where you can
decide which move to play so feel free
to pause the video even now to find
another very nice here's an idea for
black while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting yet another hidden idea and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show it's a bishop to f3 check the point
is you want the King to capture the
bishop and then you're just gonna pick
up the f4 pawn with check and also the
e4 pawn so your d5 Knight is not removed
so King captures on f3 we have rook
captures on f4 with check King to g3 and
now rook F captures on e4 so picking up
both of the pawns and with this picking
of the pawns black equalizes in material
we have rook captures on e4 rope
characters on e4 and believe it or not
this is or this has all been played
before so this position has been reached
a lot of times especially by 11 Aragon
he plays the marshal a lot he had this
position against Caruana he had it
against a job of himself who who is
playing this game he had against you
this polgár he had it against nakamura
and in all of those games f3 was played
and all those games ended in a draw but
here our job of brings a new move and
that is a 4 so it is as of move 27 that
we have a completely new game but ok now
of course you want to you want to open
up the file for your rope maybe
undermine the c6 pawn maybe maybe make
the knight on d5 vulnerable but it's not
going to be easy didn't place the rook
to e 2 he goes after the B to pawn first
we have a capture stand
five and now a captors on b5 if you go
after the b2 upon first then you get
Bishop captures and b5 Pompey a person
Iike be kept frozen a6 and this now is a
winning position for a job oh of course
ding is not going to allow that to
happen he plays a character son b5 and
now we have Bishop characters on d5
grabbing the night C captures and now
rook to d1 going after the d5 pawn dink
capture son b2 we have rook captures and
b2 rook captures on d5 and now rook to
b3 painting the pawn here while also
defending the b5 point and a job of
untains with f3 and now we have this
position where it's broken three points
each
there's not a lot to go on so ding just
captures we have rook captures and c3
rook captures and b5 and it was in this
position that our job and the ding
agreed to a draw so the first game of
the feeder World Cup 2019 ends in a draw
and although it's a very theoretical
struggle all of these moves up until
that a form would have been played
before especially by 11 Arden and and I
thought okay maybe it was a too much
over over let's say prepare the game the
show but then I thought okay it's the
finals of the video World Cup they
played the marshal gambit so I thought
better just to show this game so I don't
hope you enjoyed it and that you were
able to spot the two hidden ideas as
they're not easy to find especially if
you don't do not know this line up until
move 26 but yeah and also I will show
another game today tomorrow I will
probably show the other game that Maxime
and
and the yongi are playing for for third
place as that game is still being played
but for today I'm gonna show you a very
nice game I played in the creation chess
League as its it's a really weird game
but I'm sure gonna enjoy it so I also
wanted to mention that but yeah I wanted
to think I'm a turkey as Steven Anderson
and Stanley Mandel further contributed
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
World Cup tomorrow we have the second
game of the finals
checking up on your suggestions and soon
with the conclusion of the Capablanca
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day